استخدام همجي للتكنولوجيا ، هكذا تصف
منظمة إنسانية منظمة إنسانية
إنترناشونال
المزاد للزواج من فتاة في جنوب السودان
يقولون إنها تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا
فقط ، كل هذا تم عبر Facebook
، ورد أن والد الفتاة تلقى
خمسمائة بقرة وثلاث سيارات وعشرة آلاف
دولار  في مقابل ابنته ،
تم نشر المنشور في الأصل على
Facebook في 25 أكتوبر ،
لكن Facebook لم يعلم به
حتى 9 نوفمبر بعد 15 يومًا ،
قامت الشبكة الاجتماعية بحذف المنشور
وأخبر متحدث باسم CNN اقتباس أي
شكل من أشكال الاتجار بالبشر ما إذا كان
لا يُسمح بنشر صفحات الإعلانات أو المجموعات على
Facebook ، فنحن نزيل المنشور
ونعطل الحساب
الخاص بالشخص الذي نشر هذا
على Facebook بشكل دائم ، ونعمل دائمًا على تحسين
الأساليب التي نستخدمها لتحديد المحتوى الذي
يخالف سياساتنا بما في ذلك مضاعفة
سلامتنا وأمننا  إلى أكثر
من 30.000 ويستثمرون في التكنولوجيا
لكن نشطاء قلقون من أن هذا قد يلهم
كرة القدم الأخرى  وسائل الإعلام الاجتماعية
لمحاولة الحصول على مهور أكبر
لبناتهم. الخطة الدولية
تدعو حكومة جنوب السودان
للتحقيق في هذا الأمر وتعليق أي
مسئولين شاركوا في المزايدة
على الرغم من أنه مخالف للقانون هناك
تقول اليونيسف إن أكثر من نصف  الفتيات في
جنوب السودان يتزوجن قبل سن 18
صامويل بورك سي إن إن لندن